so seli from
Argentina 2080
had double 4
chto that plays with
C5 so now it's usually D6 or
D5 so
D4 yes now is an interesting moment yes
knight takes E4 is an
alternative so here dam die2 very
interesting
move orders
idea
D1 yes everything looks normal
here  yes, I'm just wondering
B5
yes, so black
essentially only has the idea of
moving B5 somehow, so
white should try to prevent or
at least weaken the
move now knight C3 when B5
comes then you have something good
maybe
C5
DC H well, it looks a bit shaky,
hm, yes, I'll
do that one,
so yeah, I don't know if that
was a good idea with the A4. In any case,
that consistently took the B5 out of position,
so
maybe I have it here somehow  a
trick
or something like that Bishop F6 Knight D5
because of the queen position Queen C6
probably has it, well I'll try it
anyway like this D
E6
yes now you have the really nice
knight there
and now try to play a bit so
that the bishop is more or less like that  It's
empty
so take out the check on E4 even
if it doesn't do much,
probably
so yes, that's somehow a
bit uncomfortable here for black
because he somehow can't handle this VI on d5
well either, yes
he can try that, that's the question
now  I don't know for sure whether B4 is a good breed or
not,
but I can't
think about it forever,
so you definitely won't have a good mating here,
but maybe the harlinie is
still
useful
C4
m h
surprising, yes, what kind of structure is that
If I
take it now I can hit here first,
so now theoretically even
CD would work, well, but it doesn't seem like it's
doing much, so
now
I can continue to gain space. I still have knight B6 on something like rook
C8,
but that's the most important thing
I found it surprising that I'm going to give it a little bit of gas right now F5,
but I don't think you can put it back straight away.
Time
warning, well,
come on,
activate everything. I didn't see it, it was
unpleasant, maybe it wasn't that
bad, but I saw it
anyway
don't check,
oh, I'm a DEP, I'm such a
DEP, God, check it's totally
ridiculous,
yes, that was of course a
position that you can never lose,
actually, but of course the source sets up, he
played so strangely that
it's possible again now, but I just have
seconds left
Check Check Check Check Check Check
white forit on
time yes yes of course more than
stupid of course h a position that
you can never lose with white
because it is useless to knead actually
runner is simply not good in the
position yes well adjusting is a torture
Just a simple way to lose every now and then